milos free speech week at Berkeley is a
bust and President Trump is calling out
knee dropping NFL ingrates we will talk
all manner of free speech with our
in-studio guest Dave Rubin of the Rubin
report how lucky am I
then ally Stuckey and Jacob berry joined
the panel of deplorable z-- to discuss
Anthony Weiner in the can and NPR's
lambasting the unfair exclusivity of
women's sports
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Nolt show
[Music]
Dave thank ya coming thank you for
coming on you've made the trek it's like
three or four blocks all the way I made
the trek already I hear Shapiro and
Clayton screaming in the hallways oh it
must be any time of the day yes yes be
at any point on any day of the week so
by sheer coincidence by absurd
coincidence you are here we'd already
booked you and all anyone is talking
about today is free speech the Milo
thing the Trump thing one might say it's
providential you're an atheist we will
talk about that later but before we get
into any of it yes you have a beard it's
an astounding beard it's a manly people
they're very excited you've gone on this
hermitage this Thoreau Ian Mark Hamill
Luke Skywalker Hermitage yeah what did
you learn well I went off the grid for
30 days literally off the grid my phone
was locked in a safe I did not know what
time it was I don't have a watch anymore
you're very fancy guy with a watch I had
a watch in probably 20 years so did not
for 30 days didn't know what time it was
didn't look at Twitter didn't know about
the news I was in Mexico I was working
on my book I had some family come over
not looking at her since like the most
fun thing ever you know it was Twitter
as a nightmare I mean it truly is a
nightmare and I think everyone if you
say anything about Twitter to people
these days immediately everyone's kind
of rolls their eyes their their body
language changes Twitter used to be fun
and now people are just taken over I
like a good old-fashioned trolling but
like just this order right exactly but
that but the evil people is not the
trolls I actually it's not the trolls
it's the truly genuinely evil people who
just want to burn everything down yes
and there's just a lot of those people
so even the good stuff about Twitter
where you can get your stuff out there
like just staring at your phone all day
and scrolling what's some anonymous pink
cat said about you it's like this is
probably not to know I need to know it
yeah absolutely but anyway so I didn't
shave for a month and then I came back I
did a live stream and my intention was
to shave the next day but the people
have demanded that the beard stay I kind
of dig it now I demand a juice it's
great thank you I may roll it into last
Jedi in
you know you might keep throwing out the
hair the beer comes a little bit more
I've heard the Hamel thing before well
it can't be worse than that the movie
before rogue one whatever that was the
last Jedi with the girl and it was just
not like force awakens I that is the
most diplomatic way to put it I've ever
heard it was so bad it was the best the
best acting and it was Peter Cushing and
that was just a computer-generated robot
no no you're talking about I don't mean
to insult let me see you performed in
the movie force awakens your telling you
did not like force awakens but you like
rogue one absolutely so that's very
conventional thinking okay that's pretty
conservative convention huh I think
force awakens was pretty fantastic I
loved watching the first yeah I love
three what you like the rogue one that's
what you're telling me I I liked rogue
one name three characters I I don't know
well okay name three leave oh yeah but
come on Cassidy and origin or so
baisemeaux goes your way and Google that
was impressive you did bail me out I
you're right
I can't own the characters the thing I
liked about it is there was new though
it wasn't just a remake of a new hope
you know that scene in the Middle where
Vader comes out he likes sashays out
there don't choke on your words it's
like I like a good pun I really do but
like yeah it put it put James Bond to
shame yeah anyway okay so that's only
one point there's only one point of
disagreement
I need to hear your take so I was /
you're liberal you're an old-school live
mm-hmm you're not a leftist or
regressive left you left the left you
had this great Prague review video now I
was I was reading a book over the
weekend it's called kindly inquisitors
by Jonathan Roush and it talks about
this yeah it says there are five
decision-making policies you could
either have the fundamentalist principle
what I say is right and what everyone
else says is wrong you can either have
the simple Galit Aryan principal
everyone has their own idea and it's all
fine the radical egalitarian principle
only
oppressed minorities only their views
matter yeah the humanitarian principle
don't hurt my feelings and the liberal
principle which is throw out your idea
it's gonna be viciously debated and then
the right idea will come out of it you
put into the latter category well
absolutely
realism at its core classical liberalism
true liberalism and having nothing to do
with the modern American left or the
Democratic Party or certainly
progressivism means live-and-let-live
that I mean at my core that's what I
believe I genuinely do not care what you
do in your life outside of the
conversation that we're having right now
you seem like a nice guy but like
whatever you do in the confines of your
home in it whatever you do it has
nothing to do with me as long as
whatever you're doing is not impeding on
me that's actually liberalism the idea
of the individual in using logic and
reason this is a beautiful thing
liberalism unfortunately it's been
compounded by leftism and progressivism
into this sort of monster that it is now
but it's funny I I'm a liberal I mean I
am I'm gay married okay that's about as
liberal as you get I'm not even gay I
just did it to prove a point like but
but that I'm pro-choice I'm Pro
legalization of marijuana I'm not for
nation building them for a strong public
education so all of those things but but
but the irony is I'm welcomed here in
this building where I got your page
appear oh and Clavin and you and all
these guys because you guys actually are
tolerant of of different thoughts and we
like to debate ideas and talk about I
sure and and I get invites from colleges
all over the country and they're always
from conservative groups and libertarian
groups I have zero invite from liberal
supposed liberal or progressive or
democratic groups so what does that show
you I mean who are the tolerant people
who are the liberals who are the
liberals even so all right now you have
to piss off your entire fan base yeah
what do you think about taking me what
do you think about this Kaepernick NFL
wide and president Trump calling it out
yeah well all right I have to have
consistent principles here so look they
are welcome to exercise their freedom of
expression and free speech however they
want now at the same time when you have
free speech that doesn't mean it doesn't
have any consequences so ultimately if
all these guys take a knee so again they
can do it 100% I back their ability to
do it and use their own mind to make a
decision with what they want to do with
their lives okay fine now if you're an
employer and you realize that the
audience is turning against them and may
not buy tickets may not buy as much food
may not watch what is down eight percent
temperature
which we consistently see by the way the
one guy the Pittsburgh Steelers guy who
did come out you know the whole team
stayed in lock room the one guy came out
now his jersey selling like crazy today
so he probably helped his career while
some of these guys heard it now it
shouldn't just be about your career and
money and all that the point is going to
be a wealth and stuff yeah of course
absolutely okay look they can do it
their employers can then decide if they
want to keep them or not resign them at
the end of the season or any of that as
far as Trump look I tweeted out
yesterday look the beauty of America is
that the players can do what they want
the employers can do what they want the
president can say what he wants and so
can you now a lot of people are angry
but the president said fire them look he
can say whatever he wants if he starts
putting that into law that I'd you know
demanding if he goes to cotton well
everyone thinks the president allowed to
write laws he's actually bad but I've
sort of given up on that one but Obama
thought that true though in his defense
no that I meant that as a broad sense of
what has happened with the office of the
president they all think that they can
write laws and we've sort of let them
and Congress is such a bunch of
do-nothing losers that they've just
abrogated all of their authority to them
but okay that aside Trump can say
whatever he has a right to free speech
to now what he can't do is start passing
laws that would infringe on the First
Amendment they can't start passing laws
that would force companies to fire or
stop people jail people for using their
or even to stop people from burying the
flag according to the Supreme Court
Antonin Scalia which I agree with I mean
at the end of the day these people we
have I would always err on the side of
freedom let's give more freedom and
guess what sometimes it's gonna suck
sometimes people are gonna kneel and you
may not like it sometimes they're gonna
burn the flag and you may not like it
but that's the point
so everything that happened yesterday
while everyone's screaming about oh my
god this is the most polarized we've
ever been and we're all real actually it
showed the strength of America nobody
got killed yesterday nobody got mauled
yesterday yes because they weren't at
Berkeley Yeah right wait wait till this
week but the point is that's kind of a
beautiful thing
everyone exercised their freedom of
expression now there may be consequences
that come from all of that but the
government didn't stop anybody even
Trump and by the way when I say that I
don't like what Trump tweeted I don't
like that he's put he's sort of making
it seem like the government is against
stuff and I know he purposely goes to
the line and he's kind of
the media and all of those certainly on
Isis I would much prefer a president who
I think really cared about ideas and I
really understood what his political
ethos is and all that stuff that isn't
the president we've got but it doesn't
mean you have to be dishonest in your
criticism of him that's what I would
today now what do you so the nascar came
out strongly against this the
hall-of-fame driver richard petty said
quote anybody that don't stand up for
the anthem ought to be out of the
country period we got him what got him
where they're at the united states i
couldn't agree more
what do you think about the content of
this protest so they have the right to
do it even though the NFL has fined
players for making other protests right
wearing socks honoring 9/11 that sort of
thing or we didn't dancing in the end
zone they're not even allowed to dance
in the end there's racial yeah they
should not be allowed to do that what it
what are your thoughts on the the
content of the kneeling look in my
opinion we live in truly the greatest
country probably in the history of the
world more people have come here for
more freedom than anywhere else every
single one of us unless you are a Native
American or an African American whose
ancestors were brought here as slaves
every single one of us came here with
nothing
our ancestors I'm sure you were great
grandparents or whoever it was came here
with nothing as mine did they build and
build and build we build a strong middle
class hopefully you'll be able to move
up and up and up that's a beautiful
thing now that being said are people
allowed to protest of course I mean so I
think it's slightly misguided in a way
and now we have a part we have the
perfect mix I mean this is what it is we
have the perfect storm of a president
who will keep pushing them and this
movement that's gonna keep pushing this
way and we just have this perfect thing
that's just going to keep blowing up but
ironically I think a certain amount of
people are just gonna tune out I think a
certain many people just stop literally
like two and out of the game that's what
I mean I mean even the idea I used to I
mean I love sports I never watch
SportsCenter anymore because basically
you're just watching what happened in
crime and what happened in politics yeah
exactly so I could just watch MSNBC for
that so I think that there's a short
look the other thing is so you take the
Pittsburgh Steelers the whole team
except this one guy did this
ok fine again they are welcome to do
that and they may pay consequences from
the team but how do you back
back out of that let's say let's say
Trump does a few things that they want
him to do whatever that is right or the
atmosphere changes a little bit well how
do you in three weeks from now show up
and you're all out there again as if it
all got better so they're all pinning
themselves into an intellectual corner
which i think is that's exactly right
and you make the great point to the
country is allowed people to have this
thriving middle class to ascend it as Oh
ever ever more fair ever more free ever
more equal and the fact that they can
take this protest without facing
consequences from the government is
evidence that they shouldn't protest the
country they should maybe protest the
cops or protests of this or whatever
they want well I also think that the
danger is that the the politicizing
everything is incredibly dangerous
people watch sports to escape right why
do you watch sports why do you play
sports imagine if you were playing
basketball that's a second imagine if
you were playing basketball okay you're
dribbling the ball you're playing ball
and now guys are screaming about
politics when you're on the court you
would never play with those guys again
we need a break from politics I think I
think this whole example actually is
another reason why I believe in limited
government we need a government that's
small enough that if it's going to make
decisions it can't affect us in that
many huge ways I think that would be a
much better government to have than the
government that is willing to overreach
so again I Trump
yeah he's toeing the line of what I
think is legal and what I think is right
but as far as I know he's not pushing
any laws and unfortunately people just
don't understand what the basic Preta
you know you tell people we'll First
Amendment in that free speech I saw all
these people Christmas Cecilia what's
that guy he's gone completely wrong
about everything but he's talking about
he was tweeting about you know you have
the freedom to not have consequences or
something you have the free and it's
like no that's the reverse of what you
have I'm slightly butchering what the
exact tweet was obviously yeah but like
people just don't understand the basic
concepts it's almost as if we're not
smart enough anymore because of the
failure of our education to deal with
difficult issues so I would say this is
all flow of Education actually more than
anything else is certainly that's yes
absolutely that's right and it brings us
into this other issue today which is
free speech week now you're all looking
forward to
we'd all gun all the tweets about it and
invitations and things like that
yeah and it's completely fallen apart
this was my lorry innopolis his plan his
big comeback one would there have been a
purpose to this free speech week and and
what is that purpose I like your little
pause there because it was like you had
eight questions to ask a lot of
questions above look I don't know what
the purpose was I think maybe they were
gonna intentionally try to make more
crap happen please get more violence and
all that stuff you know it's funny you
know Ben obviously who who's become a
friend of mine who I'm sure you friend
with and and I've had him on my show you
know he went to Berkeley it cost them
$600,000 it was like the president came
to town to shut down the city so Ben who
I think is in this building right now
this is what I've said publicly he's
welcome to burst in here and attack me
if he doesn't like any of it Ben
basically is a mainstream conservative
thinker all the positions that Ben
stakes out are just mainstream stuff
that's on the right basically some of it
I agree with some of it I disagree with
people were saying after the event they
were like well you know what it actually
wasn't that violent because all you know
five people were arrested and only one
ATM was destroyed a couple windows they
were like yeah so it shows tolerance and
it's pretty good but that's after six
hundred thousand dollars had to be spent
to secure this so what the real threat
is it's not only that eventually for a
guy like Ben or for many other people
that they just won't want to deal with
it you know I mean Jerry Seinfeld
doesn't perform at colleges anymore
Seinfeld no one knows his opinion on
anything you know we tried to think of
one political position that Jerry I
don't I don't see a lot of Seinfeld
political rants and yeah and yet he
thought that colleges were too
politically correct so the idea is you
either just people you know not everyone
will have the intestinal fortitude of
ben shapiro to keep showing up to these
links and staking out unpopular
positions but also the schools simply
won't be able to afford it so the threat
from about free speech and free
expression is now coming from many
directions ironically very few of these
directions are because of the government
so i fear more that we are taking it
away from ourselves we're allowing
college students to dictate what they're
taught you know I mean we've allowed
this diversity stuff the the James
d'amore memo we've allowed this to just
infect everything and it's actually the
reverse of what we need what we need is
more
people willing to talk it out and say
alright we agree we disagree but that's
the point I would much rather than weave
in a society where we disagree on some
stuff but we don't kill each other then
the society where we all just accept we
accept nonsense because we've been
guilted into it it was amazing with
Bennett Berkeley $600,000 they still
destroyed a bunch of stuff this is they
called him a Nazi I guess a Nazi Jews
man a Nazi Orthodox Jew yeah yeah he
doesn't he didn't I was at a couple
weeks ago he brought his own kosher food
I'm pretty sure you know don't bring
their own coach but when I see Ben gave
his speech and there was a lot of
content to the speech yeah he made
arguments about abortion he made a lot
of different arguments when I see you
speak you make arguments well it's about
free speech about classical government
for some people it seems to me the
speech is just about the speech they
don't there isn't actually a speech to
give it you're just waiting for these
crazy kids that jump up and yell and
then you make fun of the chubby lesbian
or some yes well yes so there's a
certain amount of people that are just
flame throwers right and you remember in
the second Batman with that when Heath
Ledger's Joker
you know Michael Caine is discussing
like the idea behind the Joker what this
guy is trying to do he says some people
just want to see the world burn so I
think we actually do have a lot of those
type of people right now which i think
is really unfortunate especially in the
system that we live in that has given so
much to so many people you know think
about if you're watching the show in
America right now pretty much you could
go to your supermarket your local
supermarket and find food there that's
pretty good pretty much there's water
running at your house you live in
Clinton again there's problem right but
pretty much in a society of 350 million
people
this thing's basically working and if
you if you travel outside the country I
was just in Cuba I've traveled all over
there is no poverty in America there is
relative poverty to because people are
so rich in America right there is no
real poverty in them and that doesn't
mean that there aren't poor people there
are people that but we have to have a
figure out how to have an honest
conversation about that not just either
throw money at everything where we
consistently find it doesn't work yeah
which we consistently find the more
money you throw at things but less it
actually works and you actually create a
session where people are now dependent
on this
I'd never want to get off it which is a
horrific position for anyone to be in so
there's so many things but this is what
the debates about and that's what I'm
afraid of right now is we're really I
mean everyone's talking about this but
but it's significantly worse than it was
two years ago we are all cordoning
ourselves off in our little teams and I
think one of the reasons that what I'm
doing is working is I'm really trying
not to do that and I'm trying to spend
as much time with a guy like you as I
would with a lefty and I'm trying to
find some answers there I think
sometimes maybe logic and reason is
gonna be the sacrifice in this thing
that might make you a trans political
thinker you know you've got one side to
the next
yeah it seems that gave me any social
justice credit you'll get your own safe
space on on YouTube the issue that I
think it seems like a trivial issue yeah
it seems completely unimportant but it's
where a lot of the cultural battle is
and the language battle in the battle
over free speech the pronouns yeah the
pronouns do people have a right to
insist that you call them by a pronoun
that doesn't match their actual
biological sex well I would completely
on this one take Jordan Peterson's
position and I'm sure how much your
audience knows Jordan has he been in
here he'd not yet but we do want to get
okay I will gladly if you don't you know
this thing doesn't burn down by the end
all apps was today I thought in question
well well write some guys they were
supposed to do what egomania to think
the world is gonna end on your all these
people that are like oh the nuclear war
is coming you know North Korea is gonna
nuke us now or they all the the
religious people that think oh end of
time you know what the world's been
calling on for a long short Carly did
something about it it's not don't worry
about the planet it's the people you
know the planets gonna be fine
anyway an answered your question I would
I would take Jordan's Peterson's
position on this which is I first off I
have trans friends I know trans people
image I do not go out of my way to
offend anybody ever well I go out of my
way to offend every but I'm sorry
that's why though so okay you have if
let's say you're walking down the street
right and somebody somebody's walking
towards you they they drop their wallet
and you're like sir you you drop your
wallet now if that person turns out to
be a woman but you thought it was a man
well
it's not your fault if you know like I
think what we're getting caught up in is
all just language nonsense what if it is
this is the real issue because we have
friends who I say identifies transgender
man to woman to man it seems to me that
a man cannot become a woman simply by
wishing it because he has a
psychological condition that makes him
think he's a woman or makes him very
much want to be a woman so let's say
he's a man but he wears dresses and
maybe he undergoes some surgery even
nevertheless he is a man my view of the
world my view of reality tells me he is
a man and I shouldn't it's not good to
play into a delusion that he isn't a man
it isn't good for him or anyone else but
my politeness tells me yeah call him a
banana if he wants to be called a banana
well well I think that's gonna get you
in trouble look I would say there's two
things there's there's something in
general like we have we have two
realities which is one is what the law
is I'm not talking about with pronouns
specifically but we have what the law is
and then how we function as people and
those things aren't the same so when
people talk about the free speech thing
for example yeah we have the First
Amendment and the first member protects
the government from you know taking away
our free speech but then there's also
just how we have to all behave with
manners it's just there's basic societal
things that you can be part of are not
be part of but that there's a social
there's a sort of unspoken social
construct and and/or social contract I
should say in being a member of society
so I would say basically if you see
someone and and you I would say do your
best to treat them this is the way you
would want to be treated but I certainly
I'm not gonna pass any laws like they
want to pass in Canada that are going to
affect that are gonna you know that they
have as policies at universities right
now yeah trouble if you use the yeah
wrong read right pronoun to refer to
something yeah all of these things are
complete nonsense I mean all of this
language policing and any law that you
would put in or any statute that you
would put in a college of course this is
just it's not only is it object drivel
but also for the people that will be
sympathetic to trans people which i
think is a perfectly fine and just cause
you're gonna actually drive a lot
away when you come in with some sort of
authoritarian thing and you're gonna
have to say this and if you don't by the
way we're gonna call you a transfer or a
bigot or a racist or all these things
that don't even make sense
trans isn't a race by the way but that
but of course all of these big
everything gets lost in all of this
nonsense so I would say yes try to be a
decent person but in no way should we be
making laws about of course we should
all be equal under the law that's it the
law doesn't say anything about how
someone has to treat you and guess what
people are allowed to be what's the
language fancier there but with the
language policy we're very relatively
correct and very family-oriented
absolutely yeah the try to be decent
that's all but you know what if you're
not decent as long as it's you're not
doing anything illegal all right what am
I gonna do because it seems there's this
the premises of it I worry with this you
did a great interview with Blaire white
I loved watching Blair White's videos I
think he makes very good points but he
would probably prefer to be referred to
as she and I and I struggle with this
question of it's a it's a small point
but if in a public space like this if we
give the premise if we grant the premise
of transgenderism and of subjectivism of
the the relativity of reality then
haven't we given away the whole the
whole form so this is where I think that
you as a conservative and me as a
liberal have have just a different view
of the world and see it's funny because
I know a certain amount people would
watch you say that now Blair if you if
you look at Blair she looks like she's
beautiful she looks like a woman okay
now a certain amount of people are gonna
watch you and go wait a minute wait a
minute he's just going out of his way
he's going out of his way to be this
kind of meaning okay now I know Blair
decently well that was the first time we
had met in person but you know sort of
know or now look you gain nothing I
think that and I think this is a fair
liberal position you gain nothing by
doing what you did there you know you
mean like you just don't like I get what
you're saying that yes this person first
off I think that trans is still listed
as some sort of psychological disorder
of some sort so psychology doesn't match
your so III if Blair was sitting here
I'm pretty sure she actually wouldn't be
a
but she would she would argue no but
even by you calling her here yeah I
think she would have a principled
position to argue against and I would
say this is the best example of why it's
about the individual that if you were
sitting here and you and Blair were
having a great political discussion
about anything
I think by the end of it you would go
you know what next time I will have no
problem calling you she call you
whatever you want to become yeah because
it's about the individual so yes at some
level I get it I get what conservatives
are kind of doing here and this is also
what I think conservatives missed on gay
marriage which is that now it's funny
all the conservatives now they all take
the libertarian position which is oh
well I didn't involve but none of you
were saying that before marriages yeah
you were not you specifically but but
the whole slew of conservatives who many
of them I'm friends with now were nobody
was taking the principled position I
Rand Paul who's more of a libertarian
obviously he could have taken the most
principled position ever and been like
you know what I don't particularly care
one way or another about gay people but
I want everyone to be treated under the
law I don't care what you do in your own
bedroom and if two people want to enter
a contract it doesn't matter what sex
there it would have been a great
principled position and something that
the right and that I think conservatives
and limited government people all could
have latched onto in a in an honest way
so I would say in this case it doesn't
really matter so I guess maybe your
pushback is that somehow what society's
raloo chipping away at a little there's
that there's a question of who gets to
define a reality who gets whose premises
do we have to believe the premise that
says that a man can can become a woman
by sheer force of will or the people who
say there are difficult facts and there
are and there are difficult
psychological conditions and we ought to
be compassionate and we ought to walk
with people and be as nice as we can
without changing definitions of reality
so I think you can you can actually Mel
both of those into one thing which again
it's about the individual so of course
if a biologist was sitting here they
would say you can't change your
chromosomes right I don't think that
most yes even the most patients patients
right but I don't even think the most
far-left trans advocate is saying that
they're changing their chromosomes but I
would say what you can do is try to
treat the individual
with respect and and I think that's
really the fertile ground that we need
to be spending more time in as Americans
right now because we're all just we're
picking positions we're fighting from
places of sort of an intellectual high
ground intellectually interesting
socially irrelevant like yeah I just
don't think it's that I think 20 years
from now if trans people it should be
what's happening to gay people right now
where they're the left is turning on
gays right now because they don't view
them as oppressed enough anymore right I
like that I'm okay with that
you don't like duress to me I don't I'm
not a president but you know what when I
but three years ago when I didn't have
the same ability to get married that you
did well then there's something to fight
for because we weren't equal under the
law but guess what you and I are
completely equal under the law right now
and that means you can treat me as
properly as you want to that's the
beauty of America we should be treated
equally under the law so you can treat
everyone but if you have a group that is
not treated equally under the law well
then they have something to fight for
right get us to that base level and then
everyone can be totally awful people to
each other if you so choose it's not how
I operate but you're allowed absolutely
now speaking of the morality of being
completely awful people to each other we
have to get into a segment I've
constructed it just for today this is a
segment that I have dubbed save Dave's
soul now yeah if you're an atheist
vaguely an atheist agnostic I'll give
you the 30-second recap on that I had
never publicly said that I was an
atheist then I had a bunch of well-known
atheists on my show and then I had Milo
on the show we were talking about
atheism and you know he rails against
atheism and basically my belief is that
if you told me I just don't believe in
things without evidence so you told me
that LeBron James dumped from half-court
last night oh well I need to see the
video on that I can't just take your
word for it so I don't think that
there's some magical being out there
that cares who I have sex with or is
watching my every move or anything like
that that being said so I sort of you I
kind of said that all right that's what
my atheism is I just don't believe
without evidence I don't want to get too
long when if you get to heaven and God
is there and you say why don't you
believe in me right and I could agree
with Bertrand Russell on almost
everything all right so there you go
what I would say is just a couple weeks
ago after I did this little hiatus that
I did I got back and I said something
how I don't
use the word atheist anymore because
there are moments I mean there are
moments in life when you have beliefs
and things that you can't explain any
reminisce yeah and and just that you we
all just can't literally explain every
little thing that being said I will play
along with your game to the best well
I'm right it is providential that we
brought up Bertrand Russell
yeah because so what I'm gonna do I'll
just run down a few arguments for God
okay see if they push any buttons see if
you have a rebuttal to it yeah this was
an argument that Burford Russell and
atheist - the day he died yes said that
he couldn't find the logical flowing
I mean famously threw his tin of tobacco
in the air he said the ontological
argument is sound and then he said well
but I don't know I'm not convinced
anyway should I brought my lawyer for
them you need your you should have this
is only only your divine lawyer yeah I
should have had a priest a rabbi and
only so this is the organ yes let's see
you might be familiar with it the
argument is well define God as the
maximally great being he comprises all
of the great making characteristics and
none of the corrupting characteristics
this is the most basic definition then
in in modal logic is a principle of
modal logic there are necessary truths
and contingent truths so this is
necessarily a mug and the mug is on the
table the mug could be my microphone and
what could be in my head now the whimsy
of the cosmos yes now yes God is a
maximally great being then he exists
necessarily right he wouldn't exist as a
matter of contingency he would be exist
necessarily so if he exists necessarily
in some possible world then he exists
necessarily in all possible worlds right
if he couldn't be the maximally great
being and only exists in some possible
don't have to be at all now if he exists
necessarily in all possible worlds then
he exists necessarily in this world
which is among all possible worlds
therefore God exists and Bertrand
Russell was reacting to a different
version of that argument basically the
same thing he said there's it's it's
impossible to point out the flaw have I
made you a Christian well well you did
say if a lot in that those are a lot of
ifs I mean these are you know these are
premises that can't be proven
empirically but so if I'm willing to go
along with that logic then I then I said
you have something there what I would
say is this I had I had Dennis Prager on
with Michael Shermer who was excavating
God immorality was one of the my
favorite we haven't checked it out you
should go over it look Google this the
Prager and Shermer debate yeah it was
really it was really interesting and by
the way two guys who I totally respect
who I broken bread with both of them I
mean I I think we did something really
nice something that I think we need a we
need more of the crux of the argument to
me I thought got to one place that I
still am not totally sold on which is
Dennis said to Michael you know Michael
is talking a lot about science and and
rational belief and not you know things
that you can't prove that you shouldn't
believe in all that and dennis basically
said you know that that's all good what
dennis was arguing was that on a macro
level that society needs these sort of
on these unspoken or these bigger than i
you know these ideas bigger than just
the literal things to keep society going
there's a little bit of what Peterson's
talking about by the way and this this
map of meaning that he talks about it's
you that at the might and i think that's
really interesting that at the micro
level we can all use our brains to
figure all this stuff out and hopefully
find morality and all that stuff but
perhaps as a on the larger scale on the
macro scale that we do need a little bit
of this I'm kind of I'm 50/50 on that
truly I wish I'd like to believe that if
we all just relied on our intellect and
science and logic and reason that we
could build a functional society that
way I don't know that there's really any
evidence that we have there's plenty of
evidence to the contrary yeah although
you know what all the good things about
America you know which a lot of times
people say these are just
judeo-christian matters these are really
Enlightenment values if we could really
grab on to enlightenment values I think
we could build a great society I don't
know that it has enough legs in a day
where so many people want to burn the
system down so many people want to be
hysterical I don't know that being a
calm sort of centrist who's open and
decent and he's willing to debate yeah
willing to debate which has got it it's
almost pointless to me I mean really
there's so many things happening right
now that whether God is sitting here
judging you one way and judging me
another or whether he's playing
racquetball somewhere else he's judging
Marshall the most I think definitely
very much on that
well I don't know that I answered your
question and even the slightest no a
little bit a little bit because you're
right every wants to burn down these
enlightenment values and I think part of
that is because the Enlightenment values
are undergirded by the judeo-christian
religion by by Christianity the natural
rights come from natural law and natural
law comes from Christianity so without
that one wonders if the society that's
based on that all of the good things
that came out of that can continue in
those good things if it's no longer
animated by the same thing that created
them in the first place well so that I
think is really interesting because the
question really is so do we have
god-given rights or does the government
give us rights
yeah so without getting too lost in what
God is whether it's this conscious being
isn't or gigantic fat man with okay so
we're a huge amount of people that's
what he is but whatever he is whether
you whether it's the Buddha whatever
that God is the fruit the unmoved mover
outside of time and space so meaning
that we have rights as human beings symp
and this is an in light this is a
science and enlightenment argument that
by York by the very essence of your
birth and your ability to have a brain
that can think that you have right you I
like you have dignity you have right to
be in this cosmos and that freedom is is
the right I think I'm about to quote
Optimus Prime freedom is the right of
all sentient beings i watch transformers
i right i cannot believe i just quoted a
prime the argument from prime he was a
pretty powerful autobot the point is but
that freedom and your ability to think
and all these things these are god-given
now whatever you want to say god is but
that they're there before government but
it's before government i like that much
more than i like that the government is
giving us these things the government is
just is a construct of man so the idea
that the government is giving me my
freedom right no no that's we can deal
with what the government gives us I
think it should give us a lot less but
the government doesn't give me my right
to be a human so again this is this is
where whether you're talking about the
judeo-christian God or whether we're
talking about you know I'm sure there
are thinkers that may be a little more
left-leaning or a little more not so
inevitably under them but sure yeah I
mean thetic Lee they might but there
might be there might be people that so
aren't that that are a little more
atheist in their thinking you know that
would that would agree with that concept
without having to do with like sort of a
conscious God and and I would fall
somewhere into that category no that's
alright we'll move you over on the okay
you think you have work to do yeah I do
notice that with you conservatives now
that I hang out with you people you know
don't think there's work thing come on
the water's nice Dave get on in here
wouldn't it be funny if I was actually
making you guys all more live even know
it make you people a lot more I know I
feel I feel it happening by the moment
you know so you bring up science yeah
and that is everyone all talk about
science these days people I think forget
that the science Western science is a
product of the church basically
Copernicus was a priest
you know we they all knock the Catholic
Church because of Galileo but Galileo
was kind of a jerk man Church was very
nice to Copernicus the my question here
is some of the compelling arguments for
God these days are more science-based it
was a it was a Catholic priest who
discovered the Big Bang George Lemaitre
and he was mocked because people thought
there was a static universe the
Aristotelian universe but he said no it
had a beginning it was the Big Bang
there is one of the most compelling
arguments didn't get me but it's a
compelling one is fine-tuning that if
you change the calculations of of the
strong or weak nuclear forces by just
slight degrees the different different
forces in the universe life would be
impossible very minor measurements do
those scientific arguments the prime
mover you need a beginning a mover that
isn't contingent or physical hmm do any
of those move you toward a God that is
that has isn't just an unconscious thing
as you just said but has a teleology a
purpose behind it
not really we got a we could do this
after a couple drinks not really though
I don't know that it is even part of
what the human experience is to
understand that
I think we can do I think there are
people that are religious that can spend
their entire lives trying to figure out
what the meaning of the universe is I
think there are scientists who can try
to find the god particle or you know
figure out through physics or
mathematics what the what the real
design of the universe is I think it is
I think that actually is much more of
what being a human is about than knowing
it I suspect early look maybe we will
get to a point one day where we will
know there will be a big booming voice
in the sky that everyone is gonna
suddenly know and maybe it'll be alien
real but you know what it could be you
see it could be aliens it could be you
know like it depends how far you want to
run with all this but I would say that
not knowing outside of time of space it
could be I mean who knows maybe well
suddenly everyone was gonna wake up with
the big like G on their foreheads yeah
and what happened there and OB guys you
know I'm telling you sign they're saying
but I would say that the question of not
knowing and being okay with that and
that not having that stunt your growth
as a human whether you want to think of
things in a religious way or in a
scientific way I think that that's what
being human is all about and you know
should ideally you'd meld the two D I
think a lot of people say that faith and
science are in conflict but of course
that is a very modern idea that none of
the founders of modern science would
have said that Newton spent 30 years of
his life interpreting Scripture yeah
well look I Stein said you know God
doesn't play dice with the universe I
think that's an interesting way of
saying it because there's an implicit
belief there then he's saying well
something God he's saying God doesn't
and Einstein he said George Lemaitre is
big bang theory it was so beautiful
that's what he what he was computer so
simple and so beautiful yeah it just all
seems kind of like smug and arrogant to
me in a way that's mine I prefer yeah
that's you seem very smug that's better
than what I'm called on Twitter I don't
even want to look at this data so
there's that one final argument yes one
I don't think you could possibly
disagree with yeah this argument is the
argument whose democratise the the
argument is that Hillary Clinton was
supposed to be President Donald Trump is
not supposed to be present was a 99%
chance that Hillary was going to be Prez
according to Princeton University the
night before the election yeah and we
got Trump then and this is just my own
empirical observations my own
experiments a blank book making fun of
Democrats became the number one
bestseller in the world now ben shapiro
serenades my dates with roaming
millennial debts tell me that God
doesn't exist tell me that it's
impossible it's impossible argument the
mystery of the universe is in folding
right in front of you and you just got
to keep rolling like that but that
doesn't prove that God exists you just
proves that the universe is here and
sometimes I think you're a little more
in line with it and sometimes you're not
you had a nice little run here and
Hillary Hillary was not lying you gotyou
is far away from you got your Trump you
got your book you got your Shapiro you
got your roaming millennial but that
just means you're doing things you know
like we always find signs when it works
to us but all day long there are signs
that have no meaning it is a wicked
generation that looks for signs and
wonders but it is a stupid generation
that ignores signs and wonders I hope
David I've saved your soul which will
integral we need I really enjoyed that
yeah we have got to say goodbye to
Facebook and YouTube listen guys we have
so much more to get to we have an
incredible panel of deplorable so we
have Allie Stuckey we have Jacob Barry
Dave's gonna stick around hopefully as
meter doesn't run out but we have to say
goodbye to Facebook and YouTube thank
you to all the current subscribers if
your subscriber go over to daily
wire.com right now you get to watch the
whole rest of the show if you're not a
subscriber hurry up man you have like
two minutes to do it it's $10 a month
$100 a year you get me you get the inter
Clavin show you get the Ben Shapiro show
you get great guests it's like dave
rubin forget all that that's nothing you
get this you get this the leftist tears
tumblr it is the most beautiful vessel
for carrying leftist tears right now
there's a beautiful vintage that we're
serving up its ever since politican
we've been serving up Dave Reubens old
boss shank use tears they know is it
yeah I'm gonna we're sending Dave on
that some go over there right now daily
wire calm we'll be right back
back to the NFL panel thank you for
waiting I was too enraptured I was lost
in Dave's beautiful eyes on the NFL the
league has apparently entered into a
golden era it hasn't have been 23 days
since one of its players has been
arrested the average time between
arrests of NFL players is 23 days but
the charges typically include drunk
driving drug offenses
oh I'm sorry the average time is 7 days
those other charges include domestic
violence assault and battery gun
violations disorderly conduct resisting
arrest theft burglary rape and even
murder in 2013 there were 71 arrests of
NFL players as Donald Trump jr. put it
if only Roger Goodell cared as much
about domestic abuse and traumatic brain
injury as he does about disrespecting
America
hashtag NFL alley is there a little man
in the mirror issue here I'm talking
about the man in the mirror is there a
connection between these guys moral
defects and their virtue signaling about
these race issues
yeah I think absolutely and that raises
a really good point that we're not just
seeing and then FL but we're seeing all
across America when it comes to virtue
signaling all of the sudden because of
the polarized politics that we're seeing
now the sense of moral vigilantism has
bubbled up in people who before didn't
care about morality all and in fact
probably would have said that they are
moral relativist but because politics is
come into play and because it's become
popular and trendy and
attention-grabbing to take a political
stance all of a sudden we have people
who care about these virtues and they
are exemplifying those virtues by making
a political point when they should be
honoring our Jacob Ali makes all
excellent points why isn't Goodell doing
something about this he's perfectly
willing to punish football players when
they honor 9/11 victims and heroes but
he will stand back on this issue why the
silence I think it's exactly what Ali
was saying it's just plain virtue
signaling I think she said moral
vigilantism that's perfect for it the
when it comes to things like 9/11 and
you know Dallas cops being killed by
black life matter sympathizer you know
it's it's so tragic and you're like oh
we just don't want politics but then all
of a sudden Colin Kaepernick takes a
knee and we have whole teams doing it it
doesn't make sense but it shows to me
the disconnect between the people who
are upstairs and then their audience who
are watching it's a disconnect with with
their fan base absolutely and Dave is
gonna cancel yes be a that's now
watching the shows okay we Adam we
talked about the NFL Jackie pay
attention to these guys anymore this is
the most football that I've ever been
subject to in my life
Anthony Weiner has been sentenced to 21
months in prison for sexting with a 15
year old girl dave is anthony Weiner's
continued existence on this earth the
final proof that the Clintons don't kill
people
well I guess yeah technically they
should have taken him out a long time
ago or at least gotten rid of the
laptops or whatever whom it was doing
over there look you know let's move on
from Anthony Weiner we have so many we
have so many problems right now this
political attacks
and all of the authoritarian stuff and
all the social justice stuff we have so
many problems like when I saw this
headline this morning was just like let
me just put that one aside let the guy
go to jail just move on you know we only
have so much brain power for all this
stuff it is too much Weiner it is Weiner
overload Ali I you're not gonna believe
this
I almost feel sorry for the guy he's so
pathetic in the court and crying and
he's obviously got this sickness this
psychological disorder should we feel
bad for Anthony Weiner
ah first one you said that I was shocked
but now when you say that when you think
about the fact that he is actually very
sick maybe in some kind of way but he
also had the opportunity to get help a
long time ago so you have to think that
after this many mistakes and after this
much time if you haven't gotten the help
that you need then it's very hard to
feel sorry for you I'm especially when
it comes to children in pedophilia and
things like that I just I don't know
forgive me but I don't have a whole lot
of compassion yeah I feel bad for the
guy and then I look at the pictures and
I think all right throw away get him out
of here in an article on Sunday NPR
lamented quote gender segregated
professional sports as being exclusive
as being unfair and exclusive alley if
we start admitting people who are
biologically men but identifying as
women and on hormone treatments or
whatever if we start allowing them to
compete in female sports is that just
the end of female sports
well yes so here is the foundational
problem with this article one of the
quotes said something like oh the reason
why traditionally male and female sports
have been separated is because males and
females play sports differently no males
play sports better I have this whole bet
with my brother-in-law saying do you
think that if I train for an entire
three years to dunk a basketball I think
I could do it and he said no he would
pay any amount of money to bet that I
could never dunk a basketball and it's
absolutely true it's not just because I
play basketball differently but because
I play basketball a lot worse than any
unathletic male it's just it's just true
and so just to say that there are
differences in how we play sports it's a
fundamental misunderstanding of how God
made the human body so unfortunately
women are you know I appreciate your
confidence in me Dave your on this
appears to be an internal conflict on
the left on the one hand there were
these immutable innate identities that
we couldn't ever possibly change and on
the one hand sex doesn't seem to matter
you can go from a man to a woman a woman
to a man so either it's the core of our
identity or it doesn't exist at all is
there any way as our resident former
leftist prezbo is always liberal is
there any way to reconcile this conflict
on the left you know my Twitter bio says
wanted to be in the NBA it's what this
is leading to is the chance that I could
maybe play in the WNBA where I actually
think I can all-star then I'm completely
for this that's number one but the truth
is I mean think about it this way I
don't know a ton of female basketball
players but if you took Lisa Leslie who
was one of the biggest stars in the
league she could never make it in the in
the NBA in the men's league that is just
simply the truth she would be she would
be crushed simply by the size and
strength of these guys that is not
putting women down that's just
understanding that we have different
biological differences so of course this
was all leading to this of course now
they're gonna try to have women play in
the NBA and but what are you really
saying here we have differences we can
accept them it doesn't mean that one's
better or ones worse it just is and it's
just reality alright which I know is
scary I can
believe that we have to end on such a
note of horrifying bigotry as reality
but panel thank you for being here ally
Stuckey Jacob berry Dave Rubin the
nicest guy in politics thank you for
coming by great to have you now it is
time for my final thought none of the
people disrespecting the national anthem
and none of those cheering them on has
made a coherent case for the protest
which I suspect is because the
protesters incoherent make no mistake
the disrespect shown is explicitly
toward the national anthem which is
itself a symbol of the country if these
football players were to kneel or turn
their backs on a police officer
their disrespect would be toward the
police and the protests toward any
alleged police brutality if they were to
kneel or turn their backs at the site or
mention of President Trump their
disrespect would be toward President
Trump and the protests toward his
administration the symbol has relation
to the symbolized but they're kneeling
for the national anthem
and so the disrespect and protests are
pointed toward the country itself there
is an irony here we pay these grown men
tens of millions of dollars per year to
run around and entertain us these men
then turn around without any fear of
prosecution and insult the country that
has given them more wealth equality and
freedom than any citizenry has ever
enjoyed in the history of the world that
prosperity equality and liberty are not
the natural state of things they are
uniquely American they rest on the
foundation of America to undercut that
foundation is to make impossible all
that that foundation secures to quote
Chesterton
there is a thought that stops thought
and that is the only thought that ought
to be stopped on that I'm Michael
Knowles this is the Michael nul show
come back tomorrow we'll do it all again
[Music]
you
[Music]